bonjour marcellin nadeau
bonjour morisod le tombeau josé des tris
auditeurs de marty qu'on est rendu à
toute l'équipe de la matinale de
martinique 1ère chef de file de nos
peuples à midi minuit monjack c'est le
nom de votre manifestation se serait
demeure lamentin pour votre rentrée
politique
une rentrée politique pour votre
mouvement qui était très actif ces
derniers temps contre l' usine gagnant 2
sur la politique énergétique de l'île on
y reviendra mais marcellin nadeau le
sujet brûlant du moment ce sont nos
ordures qui déborde de partout problème
à la signature de la trompeuse
il a fallu trouver des endroits où
stocker ce surplus de déchets on n'a pas
vu venir celle là on s'est dit qu'on ne
peut pas dire que nous soyons parmi les
moins bien lotis en matière de
traitement en fin de collecte et de
traitement des déchets sauf que la
question des déchets est liée à sa
production je crois que le meilleur
déchet entre guillemets c'est celui
qu'on ne produit pas et je crois que
nous sommes dans une société
d'hyperconsommation et la question des
déchets doit être posée donc il ya la
première solution qui est de réduire au
maximum je crois que les collectivités
en tout cas le conseil général les
communautés d'agglomération avait fait
un gros effort dessus et puis à la
question du recyclage cons et qu'on
appelle l'économie circulaire comment
transformer ces déchets je crois que ça
ce niveau là que nous pêchons il faut
absolument développer par un réseau de
ressourcerie il faut développer des
plateformes de collecte et de
transformation des déchets et en plus ce
que je crois c'est que quand nous
mettons en place des dispositifs qui
sont trop centralisée je crois qu'il
faut et d'ailleurs c'est une discussion
que j'avais eue avec des responsables
d'eco emballages des responsables
français des combats l'âge il faut
mettre des plateformes sur l'ensemble du
territoire pour mailler le territoire de
manière à traiter les déchets à
proximité de leur production vous avez
vu comment le quotidien nous rattrape
tellement vite
des petites choses comme ça des ordures
qui déborde c'est par manque
d'anticipation de nos élus par manque de
compétences ou baisser tout simplement
contextuel se dirait bien que ça arrive
et puis en règle son geste a dit que les
élus géant un système souvent c'est pour
ça que noah nous peuple à nous disons
qu'il suffit pas de gérer mais il faut
aussi rompre avec ce système et proposer
des alternatives
la question des déchets voués on demande
aux élus de venir en bout de chaîne
traiter les problématiques de système de
production complètement délirant de
production des déchets ce qu'il faut se
poser la question des consommations de
utilisation de l'usaj de l'importance
des objets que nous comme au souk en ce
moment mais ça c'est tout un projet de
société
la question des déchets n'est qu'un
révélateur en instrument emblématique
rognac est vrai qu'il faut vous les
prenez l'action 6 3 yann elies citoyens
veulent la loi aujourd'hui non justement
les et je traite à priori une
problématique ils le font bien ou mal
quand je crois que les élus ont fait des
efforts à ce niveau là mais c'est pas
cette question de traitement seulement
qu'il faut poser mais c'est la question
de la production du recyclage et de nos
modes de consommation qui sans nous
coordonner en sache un peu tout ce qui
est nous produisons comme déjà résulte
un bain de consommation de produits
importés et il ya la question si de
durand voit aussi des déchets aux gens
qui nous envoie s'agissant de
l'automobile des vhs page
alors comme je le dis à vous prenez
l'action citoyens les stray veulent de
gros aujourd'hui d'un pays qui
fonctionne bien partout sur notre tous
les secteurs mais les pays le pays
fonctionne bien il faut pas non plus que
le citoyen ce que nous disons et ce soit
dans une posture de consommateurs de
consommateurs de politique de
consommateurs de politiques publiques
il faut que le citoyen soit acteur il
faut qu'ils posent des questions des
fondamentaux du système
il s'agit pas de dire aux élus fait nous
qu'à manger nos gars ben oui nous avons
eu en effet faut que l'industrie toi
agissent pour comprendre qu'il faut
changer de logique il faut changer de
logiciel comme diraient certains faut
changer de paradigme pour aller vers une
société où on est dans la sobriété où on
mesure sur les conséquences de ce qu'on
consomme de ce qu'on achète et je crois
que c'est une autre v s'émancipe au
figuré et d'une dynamique citoyenne
qu'il faut effectivement il faut
s'émanciper c'est d'ailleurs le thème
retenu de mai pour la rentrée de nos
plats au lamentin la ctm au service de
l'émancipation quand on dit vaut
exactement par émancipation morceau est
l'ado s'est dit que nous sommes toujours
proches de l'idée que l'homme
martiniquais ou autres caribéen
le citoyen du monde droit effectivement
avoir une vie le meilleur doit accéder à
un certain bonheur une certaine
philosophie une autre vision et je crois
que c'est là la question qui est
fondamentale de la transformation
sociale
comment changer les conditions de vie
pour permettre à l'homme et aux femmes
femmes et aux hommes de vivre c'est
l'objectif de cet élément
nouvelle la cgt hier nous avons douze
autres est clairement indiquée les
limites de cette collectivité mais elle
a permis d'améliorer elle pourrait
permettre en fait une amélioration des
choses dans les moyens d'aller que
donner dans les modalités de résolution
de problèmes mais elle ne suffit pas
mais si nous voulons justement qu'elle
soit parce que une commune peut être un
outil transformation une commune peut
être qu'un outil d'émancipation une
association un syndicat mais pourvu
justement que un ballet les moyens
soient donnés à ces structures ces
organisations pour justement aller vers
cette émancipation cette transformation
mais la ctm peut être un outil même si
d'émancipation vous m'entendez pas
surtout conscientisation
mais l'émancipation elle passe par
l'action des femmes et des hommes bien
évidemment on ne libère pas un peuple ni
la formule c'est un peuple qui se lit
mais à soi même donc par conséquent si
les gens veulent accéder à ses passions
ses peur la peur leur action est
évidemment vous avez raison si ils
veulent s'émanciper
il faut qu'ils soient conscients de la
nécessité de s'émanciper devrait mettre
le pays sur des rails or demain vous
allez faire venir un certain nombre de
personnes par exemple l'historien
gilbert pago qui avec qui vous visiterez
les alliances politiques avec juste
daniel universitaire vous en remettre
une couche sur le fonctionnement de la
ctm quelque part vous ne cherchez pas
démontré un système en place depuis
janvier dernier non pas du tout nous
disons que notre position ce n'est pas
d'être compte y ou z mais d'être pour
justement l'amélioration des choses
fondamentalement ce que nous disons nous
constatons c'est qu'effectivement le
souhait des élus j'ai participé aux
commissions différentes commission
ad-hoc c'était qu'il y ait un
fonctionnement plus démocratique que ce
qu'on connaissait dans la vieille
institution départementale ou dans la
collectivité régionale wierre au sens
français du terme je sais le martinique
particulièrement et aussi au sein des
communes comme point d'une commune ou
une collectivité régionale
départementale
l'exécutif est une personne physique qui
est président d'une assemblée présidents
des exécutifs et qui ne délègue que ce
qu'il veut bien déléguer
il ya une volonté des élus d'avoir d'une
part une séparation entre organes
délibérants est conseillé organe
exécutif
alors il faut voir si ça fonctionne
vraiment parce que ça nous présenterons
d'un mental est fixé à trois
collégialité de l'exécutif c'était une
volonté forte des élus
donc ce que nous disons
interrogé un universitaire et je salue
d'ailleurs le fait que justin daniel en
dépit du fait qu'il n'est pas du tout à
nos peuples a que c'est un universitaire
qu'ils acceptent de venir dans une
espace politique pour échanger avec nous
ces questions par rapport à son
observation de spécial marcenat d'eau
qu'est ce que vous pensez du
fonctionnement de cette collectivité
le conseil-exécutif l'assemblée vous
avez entendu c'est ces derniers bruits
puisque par exemple serge letchimy n'a
pas hésité à répéter que claude lise ne
serait qu'un passeur de parole comment
vous regardez cela comment vous observez
cela est ce que ça fonctionne comme cela
le devrait je ne sais pas et c'est
seulement serge letchimy qui l'a dit je
crois que ça a été dit aussi par
ailleurs mais bref
mais je crois qu'effectivement il ne
faut pas il ne faut pas que le président
de l'assemblée soit un passeur de parole
l'assemblée a un rôle fondamental à
jouer
s'agissant même de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques un terme des six
d'anticipation termes de prospection
l'assemblée devra trouver son rôle de
garde est un élément de modernisation
des pas le cas selon public je crois que
c'est ce que justin daniel dit aussi
dans ses textes et elles pourraient
trouver ce rôle mais elle piétine
justement ce soir j'ai rejoint pourquoi
parce qu' il manque peut être une
volonté pour aller vers une véritable
séparation entre conte ces exemples liée
aux fortes personnalités du côté du
conseil exécutif non mais je ne crois
pas que les personnalités me semble que
beaucoup de martiniquais nous disait
qu'il est important d'avoir ces deux
hommes qui avaient une longue expérience
dont je crois pas qu'ils inégalité de
droit entre les deux du moins je
l'espère en tout cas c'est une question
de volonté politique
aujourd'hui il faut que l'assemblée
s'affirme comme un espace justement de
démocratisation de la musique quant à la
mise en oeuvre des politiques publiques
de la collectivité de martinique alors
nous peuple à on a fait connaissance
avec ce mouvement
justement l'occasion de la campagne
électorale pour la 7ème ans au mois de
décembre dernier
notez plat qui persistent qui signe vous
vous imposer dans le paysage politique
martiniquais on ne s'impose pas mais on
se propose et je crois que si les
martiniquais beaucoup de plus en plus de
martinique s de martin qui adhèrent
c'est parce qu'un besoin besoin d'une
autre vision besoin d'une alternative
il faut sortir de cette alternance tire
toi là que je m'y mette
sans véritable retour
est positif justement sur l'avenir de ce
peuple je crois que l'idée de nous peut
placer qu'il faut que le peuple même se
prénommait l'idée d'un peuple a c'est
qu'il faut que les gens sortent de
l'expectative sorte de la posture de
consommateurs pour être enfin des
acteurs de leur devenir
ça je crois que le pays en a besoin
c'est difficile de perdurer
c'est pas difficile de perdurer il
suffit d'avoir la volonté de le faire et
quand en face les gens voient qu'à une
détermination et bien disent ces
bouteilles unibail a dit unis abeilles a
fait et nous qu'à points et pio et je
crois que c'est sale aventures de nos
plats et les législatives du mois de
juin
c'est l'ancien nugget la sa duc à nos
peuples à nous y pensons nous y
réfléchissons mais là encore nous nous
disons mais c'est pas la peine d'aller
direction pour aller une élection quand
nous allons une élection c'est parce
qu'il ya une utilité fondamental à y
aller
dans l'intérêt du peuple martiniquais
donc si nous y voyons un intérêt
fondamental dans l'intérêt du peuple et
bien nous y mettre à l'essai n'y a pas
d'intérêt nous n'irons pas à les poser
dans le jeu mais aux chiffres de la cité
d'une manière ou d'une autre les
législatives la campagne pour y
satisfaire à un espace de débat un
espace de confrontation démocratique
dont richard fois qu'il y à espace de
confrontation démocratique nous allons
pour dire ce que nous voulons et faire
ce que nous voulons faire la rentrée
politique de nos peuples à ce sera de
notre psy chorale la montre et merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin marcenat
d'autres chefs de file de notre place